why bother the game is rigged my vote
won't count the choices are terrible
voting is for suckers perhaps you've
thought some of these things perhaps
you've even said them and if so you
wouldn't be alone and you wouldn't be
entirely wrong the game of Public Policy
today is rigged in many ways how else
would more than half of federal tax
breaks follow up to the wealthiest 5% of
Americans and our choices indeed are
often terrible for many people across
the political spectrum Exhibit A is the
2016 presidential election but in any
year you can look up and down the ballot
and find plenty to be uninspired about
but in spite of all this I still believe
voting matters and crazy as it may sound
I believe we can revive the joy of
voting today I want to talk about how we
can do that and why there's to be a time
in American history when voting was fun
when it was much more than just a grim
duty to show up at the polls that time
is called most of American history from
the revolution to the civil rights era
the United States had a vibrant robustly
participatory and raucous culture of
voting
it was Street theater open-air debates
fasting and feasting and toasting
parades and bonfires during the 19th
century immigrants and urban political
machines helped fuel this culture of
voting that culture grew with each
successive wave of new voters during
Reconstruction when new african-american
voters knew African American citizens
began to exercise their power they
celebrated in Jubilee parades that
connected emancipation with their
newfound right to vote a few decades
later the suffragettes brought a spirit
of theatricality to their fight marching
together in white
as they claimed the franchise and the
civil rights movement which sought to
redeem the promise of equal citizenship
that had been betrayed by Jim Crow put
voting right at the center from Freedom
Summer to the March and Selma that
generation of activists knew that voting
matters and they knew that spectacle and
the performance of power is key to
actually claiming power but it's been
over a half century since Selma and the
Voting Rights Act and in the decades
since this face-to-face culture of
voting has just about disappeared it's
been killed by television and then the
internet the couch has replaced the
Commons screens have made citizens into
spectators and while it's nice to share
political memes on social media that's a
rather quiet kind of citizenship
it's what the sociologist sherry Turkle
calls being alone together what we need
today is an electoral culture that is
about being together together in person
in loud and passionate ways so that
instead of being eat your vegetables or
do your duty voting can feel more like
join the club or better yet
join the party imagine if we had across
the country right now in local places
but nationwide a concerted effort to
revive a face to face set of ways to
engage in election year outdoor shows in
which candidates and their causes are
mocked and praised in broad satirical
style soapbox speeches by citizens
public debates held inside pubs streets
filled with political art and handmade
posters and murals battle the band
concerts in which competing performers
rep their candidates now all this may
sound a little bit 18th century to you
but in fact it doesn't have to be any
more 18th century than say Broadway's
Hamilton which is to say vibrantly
contemporary and the fact is that all
around the world today millions of
people are voting like this in India
elections are colourful communal affairs
in Brazil election day is a festive
carnival type atmosphere in Taiwan and
Hong Kong there is a spectacle i popping
i grabbing spectacle to the street
theater of elections you might ask well
here in america who has time for this
and i would tell you that the average
American watches 5 hours of television a
day you might ask who has the motivation
and I'll tell you any citizen who wants
to be seen and heard
not as a prop not as a talking point but
as a participant as a creator
well how might we make this happen
simply by making it happen
that's why a group of colleagues and I
launched a new project called the joy of
voting in four cities across the United
States
Philadelphia Miami Akron Ohio and
Wichita Kansas we've gathered together
artists and activists educators
political folks neighbors everyday
citizens to come together and create
projects that can foster this culture of
voting in a local way in Miami
that means all-night parties with hot
DJs we're the only way to get in is to
show that you're registered to vote in
Akron it means political plays being
performed in the bed of a flatbed truck
that moves from neighborhood to
neighborhood in Philadelphia it's a
voting themed scavenger hunt all
throughout colonial old town and in
Wichita it's making mixtapes and live
graffiti art in the North End to get out
the vote there are 20 of these projects
and they are remarkable in their beauty
and their diversity and they are
changing people let me tell you about a
couple of them in Miami we commissioned
an artist young artist named atomic Oh
to create some vivid and vibrant images
for a new series of I voted stickers the
thing is atomic Oh had never voted
he wasn't even registered so as he got
to work on the creating this artwork for
these stickers he also began to get over
his sense of intimidation about politics
he got himself registered and then he
got educated about the upcoming primary
election and on election day he was out
there not just
sing out stickers but chatting up voters
and encouraging people to vote and
talking about the election with
passers-by in Akron a theatre company
called The Wandering aesthetics has been
putting on these pickup truck plays and
to do so they put out an open call to
the public asking for speeches
monologues dialogues poems snippets of
anything that could be read aloud and
woven into a performance they got dozens
of submissions one of them was a poem
written by nine students in an ESL class
all of them Hispanic migrant workers
from nearby Hartsville Ohio I want to
read to you from this poem it's called
the joy of voting
I would like to vote for the first time
because things are changing for
Hispanics I used to be afraid of ghosts
now I'm afraid of people
there's more violence and racism voting
can change this the border wall is
nothing it's just a wall the wall of
shame is something it's very important
to vote so we can break down this wall
of shame I have passion in my heart
voting gives me a voice and power I can
stand up and do something the joy voting
project isn't just about joy
it's about this passion it's about
feeling and belief and it isn't just our
organizations work all across this
country right now
immigrants young people veterans people
of all different backgrounds are coming
together to create this kind of
passionate joyful activity around
elections in red and blue states and
urban and rural communities people of
every political background what they
have in common is simply this their work
is rooted in place because remember all
citizenship is local when politics
becomes just a presidential election we
yell and we scream at our screens and
then we collapse exhausted but when
politics is about us and our neighbors
and other people in our community coming
together to create experiences of
collective
voice and imagination then we begin to
remember that this stuff matters we
begin to remember that this is the stuff
of self-government which brings me back
to where I began my bother there's one
way to answer this question voting
matters because it is a self fulfilling
act of belief it feeds the spirit of
mutual interests that makes any society
thrive when we vote even if it is in
anger we are part of a collective
creative leap of faith
voting helps us generate the very power
that we wish we had it's no accident
that democracy and theater emerged
around the same time in ancient Athens
both of them yank the individual out of
the enclosure of her private self both
of them create great public experiences
have shared ritual both of them bring
the imagination to life in ways that
remind us that all of our bonds in the
end are imagined and can be reimagined
this moment right now when we think
about the meaning of imagination is so
fundamentally important and our ability
to take that spirit and to take that
sense if there is something greater out
there is not just a matter of technical
expertise it's not just a matter of
making the time or having the know-how
it is a matter of spirit but let me give
you an answer to this question why
bother that is maybe a little less
spiritual and a bit more pointed
why bother voting because there is no
such thing as not voting not voting is
voting for everything that you made to
test and oppose not voting can be
dressed up as an act of principled
passive resistance but in fact not
voting is actively handing power over to
those whose interests are counter to
your own and those who would be very
glad to take advantage of your absence
not voting is for suckers
imagine where this country would be if
all the folks who in 2010 created the
Tea Party had decided that you know
politics is too messy voting is too
complicated there's no possibility of
our votes adding up to anything they
didn't preemptively silence themselves
they showed up and in the course of
showing up they changed American
politics imagine if all of the followers
of Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders had
decided not to upend the political
status quo and blow apart the frame of
the previously possible in American
politics they did that by voting we live
in a time right now divided often very
dark where across the left and the right
there's a lot of talk of revolution in
the need for revolution to disrupt
everyday democracy well here's the thing
everyday democracy already gives us a
playbook for revolution in the 2012
presidential election young voters
Latino voters asian-american voters
low-income voters all showed up at less
than 50% in the 2014 midterm elections
turnout was 36% which was a 70 year low
and in your average local election
turnout hovers somewhere around 20
percent I invite you to imagine 100
percent picture 100 percent mobilize 100
percent and overnight we get revolution
overnight the policy priorities of this
country change dramatically and every
level of government becomes radically
more responsive to all the people what
would it take to mobilize 100 percent
well we do have to push back against
efforts afoot all across the country
right now to make voting harder but at
the same time we have to actively create
a positive culture voting that people
want to belong to be part of an
experience together we have to make
purpose we have to make joy so yes let's
have that revolution revolution of
spirit of ideas of policy and
participation a revolution against
cynicism a revolution against
self-fulfilling sense of powerlessness
let's vote this revolution into
existence and while we're at it let's
have some fun thank you very much